-My name is Jimmy Fallon,
and it's November 19, 2017.
Hey, Jimmy Fallon
on November 19, 2018.
Jimmy Fallon.
It is November 19, 2019.
Jimmy Fallon,
November 19th. [ Sighs ]
[ Inhales deeply ]
2020.
Good.
I'm good.
Great!
Is that a joke?
Probably a ham sandwich.
Same answer --
ham sandwich, baby.
Ham sandwich,
and that ain't gonna change.
Not anytime soon.
Whatever's in the fridge.
Whatever.
I mean, food is just fuel
that gets you through each day.
That would be Justin Timberlake.
J. Lo.
Ariana Grande!
Harry Peterson.
He's an intern at Pfizer.
Really excited about that one.
My wife.
Oh, a few months ago,
I glued googly eyes
to our vacuum cleaner.
When I turn it on, uh,
it's almost like
he's yelling at me.
It's pretty fun.
Checked my phone.
Still check my phone.
Actually, I still check my phone
every, uh --
[ Cellphone vibrates ]
What the --
Is this "Giuliani
leaking hair dye" thing real?
It's fake, right?
That can't be real.
Hosting the Golden Globes.
Uh, going to Olive Garden
with Post Malone.
That was a -- that was
a long night. That was fun.
When we took the show
to Puerto Rico.
That meant a lot.
You know M&Ms?
Uh, so -- so I get this bag of
M&Ms delivered with my groceries
and uh, you know, I wipe them
down and open them up,
and it's got, you know, blue,
orange, brown, you know, colors.
And uh, uh, this bag
didn't have any blues.
So I--I took --
uh, I opened up another bag
and I put blues in my bag.
I put the blues in my bag,
but guess what.
It wasn't in my bag because they
were -- they were Skittles.
[ Laughs ]
God, what a birthday.
One Direction.
Gotta be Jonas Brothers.
BTS.
The Cuomo brothers.
And BTS.